[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler d'un sujet
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur et
dont les philosophes finalement n'ont
pas l'habitude de traiter ce sujet c'est
le self y voilà ça ne m'étonne pas
première réaction premier sourire
on entend beaucoup de préjugés autour de
la question du cmfi la selphy le sel
finalement c'est juste une question de
narcissisme
ce sont des ego ont des mesures qu'ils
se prennent en photo l'histoire pour moi
a commencé de manière un peu différente
un priori j'étais pas prédestiné à
parler du cmfi j'ai fait une thèse en
métaphysique voyez jusque analystes une
deuxième peine et c'est le sel fille
c'était pas une évidence lors d'une
soirée chez un ami philosophe je tiens à
préciser les philosophes ont pas
toujours des jeux qui sont très drôles
pour autant lors de cette soirée il
lance un défi à tout un chacun
ce défi quel est votre point de folie
alors vu que je suis ici que la liste
aussi et que la folie ça me connaît un
peu je réfléchis un peu avant de
répondre
mais avant même que je puisse sortir une
phrase cet ami me lance toile ça je sais
ce que c'est ton point de folie pour
point de folie il ya qu'à voir ta page
facebook ce sont les ailes fille je suis
piqué au vif
je suis très étonné comment est ce que
une attitude fin un geste qui me paraît
complètement banal et anodin peut
susciter autant d'intérêt voir autant
d'émoi
depuis je lui ai répondu en 250 pages
vous trouverez toutes à leur d'ailleurs
un an sortie eh oui mes amis parce que
j'ai découvert en très peu de temps que
derrière le selphy tout un monde
s'ouvrait à la pensée et à la réflexion
ce que ce que je voudrais vous proposer
brièvement en dix minutes ce qui est une
gageur pour une toulonnaise
c'est précisément de pouvoir vous donner
à sentir à percevoir en quoi ce
comportement qui est finalement qui a
intégré nos habitudes en eau et os est
devenue emblématique voir symptomatique
des métamorphoses de notre
hypermodernité alors qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un selphy un selphy le terme est
apparu en 2002 sur un forum australien
il est composé du terme self anglais qui
signifie moins
mais aussi parfois étant seul en 2013 il
devient le mot de l'année dans les
dictionnaires oxford en 2016
il intègre les dictionnaires larousse et
petitrobert désormais le sel fille est
devenue incontournable qu'est ce donc
qu'un seul fils est très simple j'adore
faire des conférences que je vais sortir
mon portable donc à celle filles ça
consiste à se prendre soi même en photo
et a posté cette photo dans le monde la
virtualité et plus généralement sur les
réseaux sociaux
alors le sel fille n'a pu être rendue
possible que lorsque notamment sur nos
smartphones
la caméra arrière a été mise en place et
puis par la suite la caméra frontale en
cela il est l'emblème d'une révélé d'une
révolution techno scientifiques dont
vous avez déjà entendu longuement parlé
aujourd'hui c'est à dire du moment où la
virtualité est entré dans notre
quotidien
non seulement la virtualité mais aussi
l'impact de l'image est fort de ce
constat j'ai pu relever que nous
assistions à deux changements de
paradigmes fondamentaux
le premier changement de paradigme c'est
ce que j'ai appelé le passage à licques
et nook hic et nunc en latin ici et
maintenant
merci qu'est ce donc que ce rapport de
l'ici et maintenant
et bien c'est comme si notre
représentation du temps qui jusqu'àlors
se fait en trois dimensions passé
présent et avenir s'étaient repliés pour
ne former qu'une seule temporalité qui
est celle de l'instant du clic
j'ai appelé ça l'immédiat connectique
notre rapport à la temporalité et on en
a peu par entendu parler aujourd'hui
c'est un rapport à l'urgence à la
précipitation
halime à l'immédiateté au tout tout de
suite évidemment le rapport au temps ne
peut s'appréhender sens le rapport à
l'espace et là de la même manière nous
sommes rentrés dans une représentation
de l'espace en trois dimensions à une
représentation en deux dimensions ce que
j'ai appelé la spatialité horizontal qui
n'est autre que celle de notre écran est
alors merveille des merveilles que nous
recomposons la 3d de manière factice
tout un symbole que de recomposer la
profondeur
premier changement de paradigme est donc
ce rapport au temps et à l'espace
deuxième changement de paradigme c'est
celui qui nous lient au langage vous le
savez peut-être depuis les grecs et
notamment depuis socrate notre manière
d'appréhender le monde de le penser
repose sur quelque chose de très
puissant puisque notre occident à
proprement parler enracine son socle de
connaissances à partir de cela il s'agit
du logo ce qu'est ce donc que le logos
c'est un terme que l'on peut traduire
par discours rationnel
vous le trouvez dans toutes les sciences
psychologie zoologie le primat du
discours rationnel
le primat d'une vision du monde qui
reposerait sur la rationalité
or il me semble que là aussi nous
assistons à une métamorphose peut-être
qui j'ai hâte il y aurait un déclin de
ce primat du logos en faveur de ce que
j'ai appelé le règne de nay d'olonne
qu'est ce que c'est que l'ail d'olonne
l'image des images simulacre mais
combiné 1 cette modification de nos
représentations du temps et de l'espace
c'est gym ces images sont d'un genre
nouveau puisqu'il s'agit d'image
éphémère nous sommes donc rentrés dans
une ère où nous sommes passés du logos à
l'ail d'olonne au culte de l'image
éphémère et ce n'est pas cela chat qui
nous dirait le contraire
aussitôt une image est présente et
qu'elle est chassée par une autre alors
notre langue doit-on dire quand on
pourrait l'évoqué avec jean luc godard
en 2014
adieu au langage il semble que c'est sur
ce point là que le sel fille nous étonne
le plus tard en effet qu'est-ce donc que
réalisait un sel filles dans ce monde
qu'on pourrait évoquer sous la forme
d'une puissance et kramnik nous sommes
entourés de toutes parts d'écran les
images nous en faire quelle est la place
du sel fille dans un tel contexte
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
s'agit-il simplement d'une crise
narcissique
ce serait bien trop simple de réduire le
sel fille à cela et si le seul fille
était année au langage et si le cmfi
annoncé par la puissance de la
photographie un nouveau mode
d'expression
si le sel fille était une manière
d'établir un lien d'un genre nouveau
avec l'autre j'attire votre attention
sur le fait qu'il est très rare qu'on
s'envoie un saïfi à soi même
j'ai des consultations prévues si vous
voulez à la fin de rencontre et dicks
pour ceux qui sont concernés
il est très rare effectivement qu'on
s'adresse un selphy à soi même
le self y est à destination de l'autre
le self it à destination du regard de
l'autre
le self y est un néo langage jusqu'à
présent la photographie était un arrêt
immédiat nous sommes contemporain du
moment où elle accède à l'universalité
d'un langage et ce langage porte un nom
il s'agit du pic speech ou encore de
discours par l'image le pic speech très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux whatsapp
twitter facebook très prisé par les
jeunes
le pic speed ce n'est au langage ce
langage par l'image ces images
conversationnel est un langage globalisé
puisqu'ils reposent sur le développement
mondial des nouvelles technologies sans
pour autant être un langage universel
car il n'est pas toujours compris par
tous mais il tend à se multiplier il
tend à se diffuser
de plus en plus nous avons à faire donc
avec le sel fille a un nez au langage à
un pic speech alors vous pourriez vous
dire effectivement très bien le self y
est un nouveau langage
certes mais qu'en est il de cette
question du moi moi moi je car il est on
est bien d'accord
réaliser un selphy c'est se présenter
dans l'image c'est s'afficher dans
l'image c'est se photographier soit dans
l'image
quand bien même il s'agirait de
l'adresser à l'autre alors je voudrais
vous rappeler une petite histoire qui va
sans nul doute
vous parlez beaucoup c'est l'histoire
d'un jeune homme de 16 ans ce jeune
homme la particularité d'avoir beaucoup
de mal à aimer
or un jour il est pris par les assauts
d'une main ce qui s'appelle échos mais
cette dernière est incapable de
transmettre ses sentiments puisqu'elle
est condamnés à répéter tout ce qu'elle
entend dans ce désespoir non la nymphe
échos fini par disparaître et ce jeune
homme au prénom de narcisse se
retrouvent livrés à sa solitude
un jour alors qu'il est à la chasse il
tombe en pâmoison devant un superbe
paysage et la dégaine son smartphone et
prend la selphy le saïfi du siècle vous
en conviendrez
on en parle encore le cmfi de narcisse
bien évidemment alors des storytelling
des ego trip on a le sentiment que le
mois et surexposé véritable
boursouflures en 2d évidemment passe
notre temps à exister à vouloir encore
plus exister sur les réseaux sociaux
existent et ne suffit plus il faut t'il
encore pouvoir se vendre
bien évidemment est cette reine du sel
branding de l'auto promotion vous la
connaissez c'est aussi la déesse du sel
fille kim kardashian kim kardashian et
lombez n2 cette représentation celle fiq
dont on pourrait dire effectivement
qu'elle est extrêmement narcissique mais
laissez-les fils est loin de n'être que
la question de kim kardashian et vous
pouvez pas mettre sur le même plan le
selphy qu'on peut retrouver par exemple
celui de l'espace je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu le selphy de barack obama
le sel fille de la reine d'angleterre le
cmfi le musée du sel fille que qui est
consacré à ce sujet à manille
de la même manière que les sels fille
qui sont pris en véritable acte de
résistance
avec ce fameux artiste chinois ai weiwei
tous les sels fille ne sont pas à mettre
sur le même plan un selphy touristique
ne raconte pas la même histoire que le
sel fille qui vient remplacer les
autographes
le self y est un néo langage il serait
dommage douloureux de le réduire à une
question du narcissisme
et j'aime à rappeler ici que le
narcissisme est nécessaire il est un
moment du développement normal du sujet
sans narcissisme pas de confiance en soi
pas destine de soi le narcissisme est
vital l'excès de narcissisme
problématique mais on retrouve dans
toutes circonstances
pas besoin de réduire au seul fille
alors s'il est un enjeu du cmfi de ce
n'est au langage ce n'est pas tant cette
question du narcissisme me semble-t-il
que la question de la reconnaissance car
que se joue-t-il in fine est dans le
fait de prendre une photo de soi et de
la destinée à l'autre si ce n'est ce
lien avec l'autre l'enjeu dans le sel
fille c'est l'autre cfa soit l'enjeu
dans le sel fille ce n'est pas une crise
de lego s'il vit une crise de la
reconnaissance quand bien même cela
passerait par le nombre de likes
récoltés n'oubliez pas que pour être il
faut être vu on a tous besoin de
reconnaissance
on a tous besoin d'exister et
aujourd'hui cela passe par une
représentation de soi une acceptation de
l'image de soi alors imaginez bien que
la présence que notre présence que la
présence du jeu de son propre visage
dans un sel fille ce n'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une signature
alors quand vous aurez à reprendre vos
enfants en leur disant arrête de faire
autant de sel fille je vous invite
plutôt à apprendre leur langage et a
commencé à parler leur langue et pour ce
faire cher ami car j'imagine qu'ils à
nombre de personnes ici qui n'ont jamais
fait de celle fille je vous propose tous
de vous lever lumière s'il vous plaît et
de réaliser la selphy avec moi un seul
figé en pour teddy text à 3 voulu vous
criez tous et vous lever les bras
vous êtes prêts
1 2 3 ouais je salue donc je suis merci
[Applaudissements]